>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Fenella France: So welcome
everyone to today's topic
and preservation series,
presentation.
Delighted to have you
here and welcome also
to everyone we have
participating online.
The presentation today
is by Dr. Eric Monroe.
And this will be on Broken
Cylinders: Uncovering the nature
of damage to early wax cylinder
audio recordings during storage.
So Eric is a supervisory physical
scientist here in the preservation,
research and testing division.
He received a Ph.D. in chemistry
from the University
of Illinois in 2008.
Following a postdoctoral work,
following postdoctoral work
at the University of Alabama,
Birmingham and the University
of Arizona he was a chemist in
the corporate characterization lab
and came to the Library
of Congress in 2015.
I was delighted when I was talking
with him when we started talking
about degradation mechanisms
and reverse engineering.
I thought hum, I think we
have a project that's waiting.
So without any ado I will hand
over to Eric and we will learn more
about fun things we'll be
doing with wax cylinders.
[ Pause ]
>> Eric Monroe: All right.
Thanks [inaudible], thanks
to everybody for coming
and those who are online.
What I wanted to talk to you
about today was the work I've
been doing with wax cylinders.
Before coming to the Library wax
cylinders, I said what is those?
So what they are is turned
out to be quite exciting.
They're the first successfully
commercialized recorded
sound carriers.
So about four inches long and like
LPs, vinyls, they groove media.
But unlike modern disc groove
media these grooves are very wise
and very shallow.
This presents a challenge
I'll talk about later.
And also unlike the normal
grooves the audio is on the bottom
of the floor, of the groove.
So you can see kind
of a topographical map
on the bottom right or actually this
is an optical image from a cylinder.
You can kind of see how the needle
of the stylist would
write along this groove,
it then vibrates a plate
and that produces the sound.
So this was a massive change
in humanity basically.
Now we can record our
sounds and go from there.
So, one of the manufacturers
was Thomas Edison's companies.
It had a couple of different
names over the years.
And he had a group that
would produce the material,
they would sell the
material to the company
that would then cast it
and put the audio on it.
But over time they had a
couple of different iterations.
They started off in 1889 releasing
this brown wax on far left.
They were the first manufacturers
to use a homogeneous composition.
They kept that for a while.
Had some difficulties in how
they were doing the reproductions
such that it was an
instantaneous recording.
So, for the most part the band
was in the room with the cylinder
when the cylinder was made.
When we, toward the later portion
of the time before they moved
to the black cylinders in 1902
that they came up with a nifty way
of using pantograph
kind of situation
where they could have a
number of master cylinders
and then record a handful of
others, five or ten at a time.
So needless to say they got,
decided that that wasn't
necessarily commercially feasible
in the long term so
they worked really hard.
Came up with a way of
making molded cylinders,
that is that gold molded
cylinder in 1902.
From there they changed their
formulation quite dramatically
to make a four minute cylinder.
So instead of having
just two minutes
of audio they can now
put a whooping four.
They did this just by
making the grooves smaller
and upping the density.
And then they finally moved to using
a celluloid based material in 1912.
This talk is going to focus entirely
on the really old stuff,
the brown waxes.
And so here is kind of images of
how they were doing these recordings
in these commercial cylinders.
So you might the entire band,
I believe that's the Navy band
on the left and they are
recording nine cylinders at a time.
That's high throughput for them.
So they would play
the song, pull it off,
put on new cylinders,
fire up the band again.
So they were making relatively
few of these at a time.
And particularly, you know, they
were useful, interesting and the,
were used a lot as entertainment.
The very first applications were
using these auto phonographs
on the left where they
would be touring casements
with a phonograph player
inside with one cylinder.
It would sometimes be changed
out once or twice a week.
You go in, put your nickel, put the
earbuds in and listen to the song.
They also had of course home
models with a reproducing horn.
And then often times they would
be used in kind of parlors.
Now very interesting, we have a lot
of cylinders that have
music on them.
That's not where this
project came from.
It was learned and
utilized very early
on that these wax cylinders
could be used
to make ethnographic
field recordings.
So the Library has approximately
10,000 of these things.
And they start, they date
back to as early as 1890
with the [inaudible] recordings.
So we have all of these.
They're down NAVCC, the National
Audio Visual Conservancy Center.
And we're slowly going through and
looking to do digital transfers
of these cylinders again.
They've been transferred
a while ago but now
that technology has gotten better
we can get much better audio
of the material.
Unfortunately sometimes when we open
the box the cylinders have damage.
Sometimes it's a crack.
Sometimes it's a service
[inaudible].
But the biggest concern
was the cracking.
When I mentioned before that
those grooves are very shallow,
they're only about 10 micron deep,
that's the 10th of a human hair
and about 125 micron wide.
It's almost the reverse for vinyl.
So if you try and play that with
a stylist it's going to skip
and often times damage
the rest of your cylinder.
We don't really like doing that.
We are, of course do
have a developing Irene
which is a noncontact
playback method.
But for kind of high
throughput and some
of the best recordings come back,
still back playing with the stylist.
So that's where this
entire project started was,
the question is, why
are they breaking?
Why are they breaking?
What can we do to stop it?
And really is this
a ticking time bomb?
These cylinders were commercial
or basically a commodity good.
They weren't meant to last forever.
They actually in the
very early stages
when that particularly
the auto phonograph,
it was kind of a selling point
to the for bands and musicians
that these things actually
have a limited playback time.
So you're guaranteed to be
called back in to record
with us again if you sign now.
Long term employment.
It's great.
So when I was thinking about how can
we, how should I develop a project
to try and address this situation.
Just coming in from
industry, it was okay.
I'd been doing reverse
engineering of materials.
I've got all the tools in lab.
So I can go do [inaudible]
analysis, identify what's there,
make the materials and
then test them again.
Are they the same,
are they different?
Also thought of well let's
go back into the records.
What do we know?
So I started looking at some 20th
century reports, various books,
papers, things like that.
And the stated composition
was not the same
in any single one of those records.
Well okay, that was
a kind of strike.
And I'm thinking okay,
maybe I really need
to do this whole reverse
engineering.
This is going to be
much more difficult.
Then I got lucky.
I got lucky because at Rutgers
University is currently digitizing
all of the Edison Company's papers.
And as the material
was initially developed
by Thomas Edison's
companies, that's in there.
I say I got lucky because
they had digitized to 1905.
And in 1905 there was a lawsuit.
The lawsuit was between,
so not, sorry reverse.
Not only is it a lawsuit but
I also can then go through
and grab lab notebooks, which
as a scientist is really cool.
So the lawsuit.
So I could spend probably a
good hour just walking you
through the ins and outs of this
and kind of the funness with that.
Unfortunately there aren't many
images that can go with it.
So I'll try and keep
it relatively brief.
It's still kind of funny.
So National Phonograph
was Edison's company.
As I was mentioned they had,
they had released the brown wax
in the finalized form in 1889.
At the same time American
Graphophone was producing their
own cylinders.
Large, their cylinders
were paper core
with a thin mineral wax coating.
These were not very robust.
They were prone to cracking.
So they were really not
having much of a market share.
They were basically being
taken to the cleaners.
So a guy by the name of
Thomas MacDonald got in touch
with American Graphophone,
signed a contract with them
to produce a much better material.
He bet the farm on a
lead based composition
and said this is the
way we need to go.
That composition had
a lot of problems.
They would mold the cylinder very
similar to the Edison cylinders
and it would look fine initially.
But in a day or two it
would haze over the surface.
Haze over an [inaudible] surface
when you're trying to play a stylist
with very tiny little bumps at the
bottom means it just doesn't work.
So they were getting
lots of complaints.
Basically were going
to have to do a recall.
So MacDonald's bosses came to him
and said okay you have three months
to make a composition that is
as good or better than Edison's.
Get it in the factory and get
it sold otherwise you're fired.
And if you look at the details in
your contract you owe us damages.
Needless to say he got a little bit
creative at that point to the tune
of three different mechanisms
that were effectively
industrialized [inaudible].
Two industrialized [inaudible] and
one things that happen in industry.
So he got in touch with
the procurement agent
for National Phonograph
and said I'll give you $500
if you tell me what's your ordering
into the production facility.
He then hired away one
of the mold makers.
So he was just dipping cylinders
all day every day saying I will
hire you.
I'll pay you three
times what you're worth.
You won't even really
have to work for us.
All you have to do is
go across the hallway
to where they actually
make the composition
and bring me that recipe.
The third thing is he got
in touch with a soap maker
out of Evansville, Indiana.
Sent him a couple of cylinders
and said please replicate this.
The soap maker turns around,
decides yeah I'll do this.
What we'll do is I don't know how
much this will cost us but just pay,
I'll keep track of how long it
takes us, what the costs were
and just reimburse us for that.
This is kind of an
interesting challenge for us.
It's something we don't get
to mess around with a lot.
A couple of weeks later that guy
has reverse engineered the material,
recreated Edison's composition
and sent the cylinders
and the formulas back to MacDonald.
MacDonald then now has these
three different recipes.
All are basically the same.
There is a slight difference with
another one because Edison ended
up making their composition
two different ways.
I'll talk about that in
much more detail later.
So MacDonald then turns
around and patents it.
He applied for the patent in 1896.
It was awarded in 1898.
It has only his name on it.
He did not of course let
the patent office know any
of those three levels of trickery
when he received the information.
So now this is a lawsuit in 1905.
That's nine years later.
What happened was when,
so the two companies ended
up just manufacturing the same
material over that time period.
Edison knew that he didn't
really, he couldn't do anything
because he didn't patent
the material.
He was using it as a trade secret
saying no one will understand what
my secret sauce is.
So there's the patent.
And so the only way that National
Phonograph could not lose this suit
very badly and particularly
since the lawsuit's
basically saying you've done,
you've been using this composition
since I invented the composition
so you've got now nine
years of infringement.
But what triggered
this was Edison's move
to the two minute black
wax cylinders.
The gold molded process.
The two compositions are
very, very, very similar.
All they do is they changed a
little bit of the ceresin wax
to ceresin and carnauba wax.
That is a derivative work.
We would probably both invalidate
Edison's patent and possibly lead
to a large loss on Edison's part.
So in order to get around that
all they had, or they needed
to show prior, they needed to show,
no we actually developed
this back in 1889.
And we've been doing
that ever since.
So in the deposition
is many, many, many,
many pages of Jonas
Aylsworth's testimony.
And in this process he says I
am the one that invented this.
In 1888 we finalized
the formulation in 1889.
And these were all of the steps
that I took to get to that point.
And we were producing this form,
see lab notebook experiment X
at XY&Z places from
these time periods.
And then we moved to
here and did this.
We did this.
And then we changed the
formula because of this reason.
And these are the two
that are in the patent.
So this got quite interesting.
And so, on the bottom right is
just a, from the brief were saying
that the letters patent
hereupon is invalid and void
because the same was obtained
surreptitiously and unjustly
for the invention which was in fact
invented by the author or others
who were using reasonable diligence.
Basically we created it
and you didn't create it.
Your soap maker made it for you.
So this now gives me a
great wealth of knowledge.
Not only do I have all of
the legal or legal lead,
basically binding recipes,
I also have reference to all
of the lab notebooks which I can
go into and science geek out at.
So what is this material?
Don't get concerned by all
of the chemical structures.
It's relatively easy.
Basically he used the process used
to make soap with two minor changes.
Instead of using a large
fat which has three
of these fatty acid chains, they
used a purified steric acid.
Back then it was a one to one blend
of the steric and palmitic acid.
You melt that down and
you add in some base,
sodium hydroxide or
sodium carbonate.
They used both at one point in time.
That is the same process
for making normal soap.
The magic here was they
didn't add so much base
that it turned everything from
the acid form to the sodium form.
They also did this in
the presence of aluminum.
The aluminum was their,
was their secret sauce.
That's the, that aluminum stearate
gave them the right physical
properties for wear resistance
and the ability to mold
and basically make
nice little chips.
If you had too much sodium
stearate it goes crystalline.
If you don't have enough of the
sodium stearate it is too soft.
And so this was that thing
that was in the middle
to give them some leeway
during production.
They also then had to add
a little of the ceresin wax
to basically soften the material
and to make it water resistant.
So I want to go back
in the lab notebooks.
And so having these kind of
lab notebooks gives you an eye
into what they were
actually thinking
when they were developing
this material.
And I actually highlighted
a number of things
that weren't in the patent.
A lot of the failure
mechanisms that we see now
with the cylinders nowadays,
they knew all about back then
because they were actively
developing their materials
to not have those problems.
The various hazings, the surface
defects, they were all noted.
And well I've got his
lab notebook on my iPad.
I've read through most of them.
Thankfully he has pretty
reasonable handwriting.
So this experiment 857
is his ah-ha moment.
Up until this point
he had been using,
he had been going similar route
as American Phonograph had
using various mineral waxes
in various combinations trying to
make just the right properties.
[Inaudible] say well
what if I make some soap?
So he did.
And it, what this was was he took
his steric acid and sodium hydroxide
and did just the partial
saponification.
So he did, he just added, you know,
about 50% of what he
needed for the base.
And when he cast that carb to groove
he says it cut to almost perfection.
He then continues, until
basically a couple of days later
when it became a little bit
crystalline so it made a lot of pops
and it was very sensitive to water.
So he's like okay well but
this was a changing moment.
This was the basis for everything
that happened over
the next 20 years.
So he realized at that point if he
added another metal he could have,
start to tease out
various properties.
So here 871 he stumbles
upon aluminum acetate.
So here he is adding the
aluminum in in this form
in the hot molten magma bath
it's basically like napalm.
It's about 400 Fahrenheit by
the time you're done with it.
So it's, you don't
want to get it on you.
But in the process this releases
acidic acid so he doesn't have
to worry about having something else
in the soup other than
his pure aluminum.
It worked nicely.
He's like well let's
do some other things.
So he spends the next couple
of months looking at all sorts
of other metals, lead, nickel, iron,
you know, the list goes on and on.
He had about another 30 or 40
different metals he had looked at.
And decided no, aluminum
was the best thing for us.
He then went and had to optimize his
method so he could then scale this
up from doing it in a
couple of pounds to doing it
in a production scale
in large metal kettles.
So then they start
making that material.
That was in December of 1888.
They then cast the
number of cylinders,
took them to their
recording department.
And the recording department was
complaining because it kept wearing
down their shaving knives.
So it would come out the mold
and then it be made smooth.
And they couldn't keep a sharp edge
because the material
was just too hard,
they couldn't cut it
in a production scale.
So, they went back, he's okay,
I'll just add oleic acid,
it'll soften, it will be great.
It was great for a couple of months
until summer happened in New Jersey.
So June, 1889 now they're
getting all sorts of complaints
because well yeah it's softer,
it takes a groove great,
it sounds great.
But then humidity comes
along, a little bit of heat
and now the surface
is no longer shiny.
Now it's just exuding what he later
figured out was the oleic acid.
So he knew he had to get rid of that
but still put in something softer.
So that's he stumbled
upon the ceresin wax,
it's just a hydrocarbon.
He can throw that in.
And it has the added benefit
of not only making it softer
but removing the oleic acid.
From there he wanted to change the
way they were adding in the aluminum
in a large part because they
were trying to up the process
and if you didn't boil it long
enough you had acidic acid there.
If you had any acid leftover as
soon as it came out of the mold
and saw a little bit of moisture
the entire cylinder would just
haze over.
Again, not what he wanted.
So he'd also decided okay
well let's make the aluminum
[inaudible] offline.
This will allow us to, we'll just
make a bunch of the aluminum stearic
because we added in
relatively small amounts.
So we can make it in big
batches instead of in one pot.
Set it aside and just
kind of sprinkle it
in as seasoning whenever
you need to.
He then cut costs by changing
from sodium hydroxide
to sodium carbonate.
That's also a whole lot safer
because to add the sodium carbonate
as a powder instead of
liquid sodium hydroxide
into 400 Fahrenheit boiling
pot of effectively oil.
This was a method that they then
ran with for a number of years.
Jonas Alysworth actually
left this project.
And I think at that point
in time went on to go work
on I think it was the
lightbulb production line.
Until they started to have
a lot of more problems
about six years later, so 1895.
It turns out this is
also the same time
that MacDonald was snooping around.
So I said that there was two
different copies that he had.
One was the second,
this other method
where when Alysworth came back
and was identifying well what the
problem was, he looked in the vats.
And when they were making the
stearic acid they're supposed
to put them into pans
and cover them.
Well production had gotten enough
and they had been doing
this for long enough.
They said awe we'll just cut
out the whole cover it problem.
So they were making the aluminum
stearic putting it in pans
and then leaving it in
the room for a couple
of months until they needed it.
So it was just dirt
and grime and dust
because it was an industrial
situation.
So he went back and okay, we'll
just use this all in one pot
and we'll just throw
in a chunk of aluminum.
It turns out it actually works
and it was quite simple to do.
It's all one pot, throw everything
in, boil it until it stops boiling,
cast it and we're good to go.
So these were the two
methods that he had used.
And needless to say I've got a
lab, I'm going to make these.
I made not only those last two that
they did the long scale production
but each of the ones that I had
just talked about was something
that they had produced
commercially outside
of that very first one
at some point in time.
When I mentioned that the
material's quite easy to make.
The ones that are on the bottom
for reasons I'll explain
here shortly were all made
by a high school graduate
student that I had
as a summer intern last summer.
So we made these materials but
we actually learned something
in the making of the materials.
One of which was that my
materials were too pure.
In my first iteration of trying
to make these materials
I was using stearic acid
that I purchased from
a chemical company.
It's 100% pure almost.
In going through that process
I always saw crystallization.
It wasn't until I was flipping back
through the notebook and he noted,
our stearic acid, we had
these specifications.
It can be 50% palmitic
acid, 50% stearic acid
and no more than 2% oleic acid.
Oh, yeah that'd do it.
Just having that slight
different length was needed
to make that amorphic material.
When I started blending the two
together it went from something
that had always formed crystals
on the surface to something
which is perfectly amorphous
and by hand is identical
to the materials I was
seeing from way back.
Also learned that the color of the
cylinders is a, it's a function
of the time, temperature and
metals that the material sees.
So these things were made in a cast
iron kettle, kept warm for a while.
They then were poured out
into pans to solidify.
They were then taken across
the hallway when needed,
the cylinder molding room,
they were melted down again
and then they were
cast into cylinders.
So by the time, the amount of time
I just kept this thing boiling can
dramatically affect the
color of my material.
This was somewhat novel
in looking at those people
who have been looking at
cylinders and mostly home hobbyists
that are interested
in these materials.
Some of them had been thinking that
because there's such a variation
in color of the cylinders
that it was actually
that they were always
tweaking the recipe.
Well the data or I can replicate
that change here as well
as looking back in all the
records to know it was a very,
very stable composition that really
only had two compositions they were
ever really making.
So I also mentioned metals.
So when we started looking at
the composition of cylinders
from our collection we saw that
more than just sodium and aluminum
as the metals which we
would expect to see.
So here using x-ray fluorescents,
basically it's a little x-ray gun,
put it up next to the
thing, pull the trigger,
the x-rays excite the metal
atoms that are in the material
which then emit another photon with
certain energy that we can measure.
And that energy is,
corresponds to the elements.
So we can identify what they are.
In this case we can't
do it quantitatively
but we can see what
elements are actually there.
So we don't have much of a response
for sodium and aluminum here,
that's because it's a limitation of
the method and how I was running it.
But I do see a lot of other things.
I see a fair amount of Sulphur, that
was a contaminant in the ceresin.
Calcium shows up from time to time,
nickel was an interesting
one as was the iron.
So those came from the kettles in
which they were making the material.
More often than not they were
producing in cast iron kettles
so just a contaminant from that.
The nickel was from a
very brief time period.
I think it was, it was less than
a year where production was moved
to the Silver Lake facility
because they were renovating
another manufacturing plant
and they had nickel kettles.
So I actually had one that
likely came from there.
We also had a couple that
hit positive for lead.
Those were likely from the American
Graphophone or some knockoff there
who was using their composition.
So we have all these metals and
going back to the lab notebook.
Oh, oh, what's going on?
Do these metals have an effect
on the properties and material?
I can make the really
pure stuff but does
that really simulate what I have?
Does it matter?
Well it turns out that the having
iron at levels which we detected
in the material did
change the color.
It actually made it a whole lot more
similar to the cylinder material
that we see in the collection.
So it does have an effect on color.
Next question would be well how does
this relate to overall properties?
So really it's now time to get down
to the nitty gritty and the science
of what do, what did I make?
Are my materials similar enough to
the old broken box of sad things?
Thankfully most of those are blanks.
Unfortunately not all of them.
And in our collection again
sometimes we see cracks.
But the question again
is well what changed?
Is the things that I've just made
are they the same or as what I have
in the box whereas when the box
broken because things are degrading?
In which case it's all
hands digitalis time
to just digitize everything used and
the best techniques we have in order
to not lose any more information.
So one way to do this is to look at
the exact or the quantify the level
of metals in the cylinders.
So I can do this very
sensitive or very sensitively
by taking a small scrapings
from the inside of the bore
of a cylinder or of a fragment.
In this case this was a blank with a
big hole in the back you can't see.
And this amount of material is
enough to do about ten analyses.
So I can use a very small
amount of this material.
We then digest it down and shoot it
into this fancy piece of equipment,
inductively coupled plasma
with optimal [inaudible].
Basically it throws a liquid into
a plasma similar to what you see
if you put a fork into a
microwave except this is
in an argon atmosphere
instead of air.
So it's an argon plasma.
It has a little coil just
like your microwave does.
It's very, very hot.
It excites the metal
elements similar to the XRF
that I was talking about before.
It emits another photon.
We measure those.
And now we can identify
what elements are there
and at what quantity.
When we do that we get
a whole lot of numbers.
Don't really need to go
too far into this one.
The most important thing is
to look in this top right.
This is the only cylinder
that I have tested in this way
that has a known provenance.
This was a cylinder from 1890.
That was when they were
making composition 1058.
My aluminum and sodium levels
are very, very similar.
We were making what we
thought we were making
or I was making what I
thought I was making.
They were making what they
thought they were making.
Using all of these numbers
is where the project
for my summer student came.
And so he doped in all
of these materials or all
of these other metals into the
compositions in order to make those,
that second set that
was much more brown.
So our metals are there but none
them were radioactive metals.
So they're not decaying,
they're not going anywhere.
They are what they are.
So then it's what about the
other portions of the cylinders?
What about the organics?
So for that we can take
a little glass rod.
Touch it to the interior of the
bore, of the cylinder and put
that in front of our
mass spectrometer.
So in this case I've got yet
another plasma, air plasma,
not actually helium, sorry,
coming through the blue piece
of instrumentation on the right.
That then bounces ions
off of our glass surface
that transfers the charge.
And desorbs our analyte which
then gets sucked into the vacuum
of our mass spectrometer which
tells us the molecular weight
of the things we just threw into it.
Once we do that we get some
other data that looks like this.
What it is is molecular
weight on the bottom
and relative intensity
on the y axis.
I can identify almost all of
those peaks as salt adducts
or fatty acids themselves
through this process that sodium
and aluminum stearate component.
The metal gets knocked off so
we just see the acid forms.
And these three higher
were here are complexes
of stearic and palmitic acid.
So it's two palmitic, two stearic
or one of each stuck together.
The really important thing here is
I've looked at this in great detail.
And in many different
ones of these I've taken
from different cylinders
and all of mine.
And I really only see
two differences.
In the period brown wax on the top
I see the presence of oleic acid.
I don't have that in mine
because I didn't add it.
I'm using pure materials.
Later on I did add in oleic
acid to get that kind of signal,
it's right in that
one or two percent
which was the specification
they were using in the way back.
Kind of cool.
I also know where my suppliers
are getting their stearic acid
supplies from.
It's coming from cows because
I see margaric acid, margarine.
So but I see no evidence of
any degradation products.
I would expect to see either
something down here or something
in through here that's
different between the two
if I was seeing some degradation.
Either a reaction that
things come together,
gets a slightly larger mass or
things fall apart, they get smaller.
So the stearic acid and palmitic
acid aren't degrading, okay.
What about the ceresin wax?
Didn't see that in using the
previous method, the [inaudible],
so I dissolved the stuff up in
some chloroform and shoot it
across a different instrument, a gas
chromatography, mass spectrometer.
Basically it separates the molecules
out by roughly molecular weight
or hydrophobicity and then puts
them into another mass spectrometer.
Breaks them apart so I
can see what they are.
This is just a trace
of the separation.
And you can see that the two
period fragments are, well,
pretty much indistinguishable
from what I had made in lab.
The bottom is the raw
ceresin wax that I was using.
I've used a couple of
different ceresins,
the slightly different
molecular weight.
But even the top period looks more
like the ceresin than the period,
to period comparison but it's
still the same as my lab prep.
So now I've looked at everything and
I see no differences outside of some
of those additional metals.
Time to look at some
physical measurements
to see if I can explain that.
But it doesn't appear that we're
actually chemically degrading.
This is great.
It means we likely have some time.
But it means at this point I
didn't know what the cause was.
So let's look at hardness.
Hardness was a big thing
that they kept measuring
and harping on in the notebooks.
So I have all these previous
cylinder fragments to the left
that were melted down into
little pucks as well as two
of my compositions, that 1058 and
the 38 were the commercial forms.
And I'm right at the right hardness
as the period, okay, that's good.
That 892 and 957, those were
the materials prior to adding
of the ceresin wax where
they said it was too hard.
Okay, it actually was too hard.
So then I decided okay well one
thing is when I cast these things
in these little cups, little
melt aluminum cups they shrink
and I can easily pull them out.
It makes analysis really
easy and you can see how
that would be in a little mold.
But how much is it
actually shrinking?
So I did a series of experiments
where I took these cylinder pucks
and measured the diameter
in multiple places across it
and multiple temperatures
and humidity's.
Did the hardness of the same thing
with temperature and humidity.
These things really do not care
about the humidity, the differences.
But I do see a sizeable expansion
when I change the temperature.
I can quantify that by using the
coefficient thermal expansion.
Basically it's a measurement of
if you change the temperature
of an object x degrees it will
expand or contract by this fraction.
And what I found was these
materials, so the period cylinders
as well as the 1058 and 38
compositions are, have a coefficient
of thermal expansion of about 200
parts per million per degree Celsius
temperature change.
What does that mean?
Well it means that these things
are changing quite a bit.
A cylinder will expand or
contract about 10,000ths of an inch
at the 20 degree Fahrenheit change.
To put this in perspective modern
plastics their coefficient expansion
is about 150.
These materials do expand and
contract if you're making a mold
to produce a glass or something.
You need to account for that
shrinkage otherwise you're not going
to get the right measurements.
But those polymers that make
up the plastics have molecular
weights in the millions.
They're incredibly large.
Stearic acid and palmitic
acid have molecular weights
between 200 and 300.
There's just not a lot
of interaction there
that can hold the materials
together.
Seeing this data in
the first iteration,
so this is about 20
different samples
and there's 55 across all of these.
Most are in the 1058,
38 compositions.
When we first saw that information
we immediately called down to NAVCC.
How are we dealing with moving the
cylinders from the collection spaces
into the recording studio?
Because I think we might
need to talk about this.
So in doing so, it's like
okay, let's make cylinders
to make sure before I
undergo any big process change
that the theory at, this is just a
thermal effect could be plausible.
So I don't have any molds from
the late 1800s sitting around.
So I went down to Home Depot, picked
up some iron pipes with a little bit
of silicon in the middle
to hold it together
so it doesn't leak
all over my bench.
And cast some pseudocylinders.
I'm calling them pseudocylinders
because the diameter's not quite
right, it's a little too small.
But the wall thickness
is spot on for period,
for historical cylinders.
Could then take that and be harsh
to it, really mean and cycle it
from zero degrees Fahrenheit
to 100 degrees Fahrenheit
in the time it took to
walk across the room.
I'd done some measurements
on how rapidly the waxes will
equilibrate to a temperature change.
And the answer is normally
about five minutes.
So we're doing this much
harder, much faster.
But in just cycling 8 to 12 times
we were, we're causing cracks
in our cylinders that look just like
what we're seeing in the period.
So it's not that the
materials are degrading
but it's been thermal
shock over the years.
Now we're taking it really quickly
but changing even 20 or 30 degrees
or being in an attic in
the summer or a garage
in the winter and the summer.
And having that thermal
cycling in the course
of 120 years it makes
plausible sense.
Our cylinders are living in
a very acclimatized space.
They're back in the vault at NAVCC.
They're actually back
behind this facility
in that mountain in
Culpepper, Virginia.
And so the vault conditions
are very stable
at 50 degrees Fahrenheit,
50% relative humidity.
The cylinders had been going through
an acclimatization room which is
at 65 Fahrenheit and 30% relative
humidity so slow the transition
of the humidity, to
slow that transition.
Because all of the other
recording materials
down there they are more sensitive
to the effect of humidity changes
on them rather than the temperature.
Here we're the opposite
because then they were going
to the recording studio,
you know, at 72 and 30.
We did a very, okay not really.
So sometimes the best
solution is the easiest one.
Now instead of our
cylinders going from the vault
to that acclimatization
space on a cart
in the little boxes they
now get to take that trip
in a fishing grade Igloo
cooler which can slow
that temperature shift from a couple
of minutes to now 24 to 48 hours.
So we're trying to make that
transition as slow as possible
and limit the number of cycles
that they see that anyway.
The same time it makes
it very important
that when people are handling the
cylinders they do what they've been
doing since they were taught
how to handle cylinders
which is to keep them moving.
Because just the touch of your hand
can change the local temperature.
The four minute black [inaudible]
are really notorious for that
because they're much more brittle.
It turns out they have the same
coefficient thermal expansion
as these other ones.
So not only were we able to
say that yeah our collection is
in relatively good hands, it's now
in its happiest place they could
possibly be as the temperature
and humidity are now
nice and constant.
And we take steps to slow any sort
of thermal transition
that we may have.
With that we think we
can reduce the risk
and has come together what I
think at least is a really kind
of interesting story
that all started off
with the really kind of worrisome.
Are we going to lose
this entire collection?
And so we have to just
take everybody
in do this mass digitization.
What it really likes like
now is the cylinders look
like they're going
to be quite stable.
They're much more stable than any
of the current discs that we have
with CDs, DVDs, Blue
Rays, things like that.
So now we can decide what do we
need, what kind of effort to we need
to do the preservation by saying
okay what is at most risk?
In this case the cylinders
are much better off
than we thought they
were to begin with.
And so with that I need to
acknowledge a number of people.
Fenella and the folks in the
PRTD have been great help.
So was Andrew Almeida, he
was my summer intern student.
He's now a freshman at the
University of Maryland.
Peter Alyea for a lot of helpful
communications as well as NAVCC
and the Folk Life Center for really
making this project possible.
With that I'll gladly
take any questions.
[ Audience Applause ]
>> Fenella France: I just want to
say I think the only time in my life
when someone on my staff
has walked into my office
and says I've just broken something.
I went yes [inaudible].
So we'll open this up to questions
and Eric will actually
repeat the question
for our online folks as well.
[ Pause ]
>> Eric Monroe: No questions, oh.
>> Hi there.
I think I saw a [inaudible]
image, a 3D of that.
I'm wondering if you're
considering using visualization
of the cylinder before,
before subjecting it
to imaging or [inaudible]?
>> Eric Monroe: Sure so the
question was whether or not,
since I had the 3D image of the
grooves if we're using that prior
to doing a transfer,
something like that.
That is the Irene process
in snapshot.
So it was something that the
library's been working on
and developing with folks
at, I really lost it,
at Berkeley National Lab, sorry,
which uses an optical probe
to measure the depth and image
the depths of those grooves
which then we can play
back with an algorithm.
So it's been quite useful.
[ Pause ]
>> You talk about the
[inaudible] still cracking.
Do you ever see any flaking
[inaudible] cracking?
>> Eric Monroe: So the question
was if we ever see any flaking kind
of cracking rather
than a straight crack?
I haven't seen any on any of
the fragments that I have.
It doesn't mean it doesn't exist.
I'll have to reach out to the
folks at NAVCC to see if that's one
of their failure mechanisms
that they do see.
>> You looked at the [inaudible]?
>> Eric Monroe: We do on occasion.
Mostly those are, the only
time I've ever seen that is
when there's a much larger
crack and the pieces come off.
I guess by, you know,
abrasion in and out
of a box you might see
something like that.
But as far as a failure mode itself
I haven't necessarily seen it.
I wouldn't expect it as the
material itself should be amorphous
so it shouldn't have any
interior stress points
that would just flake off
a little particle unless
that stress point kind of loops part
way through and then comes back up.
In which case it's possible,
I just haven't seen it.
>> I was wondering if
you're accelerating
and heat testing [inaudible]
for how many
of those thermal shocks it may
take to cause some of this damage?
>> Eric Monroe: The answer is
some and probably quite bit.
We needless to say haven't, I
didn't inflict the port intern
to doing 100 Fahrenheit
to, you know,
what we see over a normal cycle
of going form say 100 down to 60
or 80 to 60 if it was in the
sun and in the shade in a room.
The fact that it does
happen is promising.
I mean, I'm not saying that this is
the definitive reason why everything
is happening.
It's very plausible
in this point in time.
We do, I did have, do have
some plans of kind of reducing
that to see if I still get it.
That can give us a better idea.
At this point for preservation
it's try and minimize it as much
as you can just like anything
else is try and minimize the risk.
>> Very interesting presentation.
I'm wondering, I'm sure you
haven't done a massive survey,
all media throughout the world.
But from what you've heard
of, from what you're familiar
with would you be able to perhaps
make a guess as to which other types
of media might have similar issues?
>> Eric Monroe: So the question
is if I can think of other media
which have a similar
issue to the cylinders?
I mean, there's kind of two
failure modes that we see a lot.
And those are more with
the modern materials
where there's delimitation
of various layers.
This gets around that by just
being one material in a whole.
That's some of the problems
with the other cylinders.
I'm trying to think.
>> Fenella France: Unless you took
the [inaudible] already looking
at all the different types of audio
visual materials that are different
in the way they're
played and the background
and so we're looking
at those [inaudible].
This is very specific.
>> Eric Monroe: Yeah
there was outside
of the cylinders once they ended
up with the wax cylinders
then they went
to plastics from there effectively.
So everything went to completely
different style of polymer.
So I'm trying, yeah
I don't really think
of anything even used these
materials once they move
to the four minute waxes.
[ Pause ]
>> So if you haven't seen any
evidence of chemical degradation,
it all seems to be
thermally induced.
Do you think there's maybe a case to
be made for not storing them at 50
and storing them or 50 Fahrenheit
and storing them at 70 [inaudible]?
>> Eric Monroe: Sure.
So the question was
since we're seeing
that thermal is the likely problem,
does it makes sense to
not store them at 50?
Part of the reason to store them
cold if to prevent any other kind
of degradation that might happen.
There's some evidence that there
can be some transfer from encasement
or the boxes or something
like that onto the surface.
So trying to, you know, even
if the cylinder's not degrading
the box it came in might.
And so I've got a summer student
that starts next week who's going
to be looking at what kind, what
are the other failure modes that are
on the surface of the
cylinders as well as coming
up with better ways
of doing the cleaning.
Now if you don't have access
to a cold storage room
keep them where they are.
The cylinders will
spend most of their life
at room temperature
rather than cold storage.
But down there I think
that's about all we've got
because it's just underneath,
it's in the mountain
so it's like an almost cellar.
>> That was my question.
Yeah and I think that it comes
with so many materials it's
the fluctuation, you know,
[inaudible] that keeps heating
up those potential failure
modes [inaudible] materials.
>> Just a [inaudible].
It would be interesting though
to say for an institution
that was maybe able to
house the material, the,
put them in a temporary
[inaudible] and stable
and you can't [inaudible]
climate control the areas
that could be a new, new room
for best practices as far
as [inaudible] preservation
for housing.
And you keep recommending that you
keep them at a higher temperature
to avoid the [inaudible].
>> Eric Monroe: Right.
So the statement was along the lines
of if they can't [inaudible] place
with these cylinders can't afford
it, doesn't have the access
to colder storage then,
you know, rehouse them
and then keep to into another space.
And in that case it's
yeah, you want to be
as climate controlled as possible.
Whatever it is just keep
it as stable as possible.
And thankfully most of the
storage spaces are now designed
to be rock solid for that,
for special collections
and things like that.
>> Fenella France: And I think
what's really interesting is
that to be able to say you don't
need to worry about humidity
for these materials
[inaudible] is huge.
The other thing would
[inaudible] look
at is the cause quite often a small
organization will transfer them
to another location
to be transferred.
One of the implications into the
transportation of trying to control
and not we, you know,
actually doing more damage.
Though I think that's another
question I'd like to talk
with [inaudible] colleagues about
and, you know, probably think
about that and keep [inaudible]
recommendations for [inaudible].
Do I see a hand in the?
>> I was just curious.
I understand it's about
storage that you've been doing.
What is the process for putting
the broken pieces back together?
>> Eric Monroe: Right
now there's not,
so the question was
what process do we have
to put the broken pieces
back together.
And right now unfortunately there's
not a lot of options if it's really,
really broken to a bunch of pieces.
With Irene we've been
able to stitch together,
kind of if it's broken off a U
chunk or a big piece we can piece
that back together again.
Image that and then fix everything
basically using Photoshop
for cylinders, Photoshop for audio.
And so if there's large
pieces we can do that.
And I think the plan is with
the [inaudible] iterations
of the software is to be able to
basically image individual pieces
and then stitch them all back
together in the computer.
So as long as we had all
of the pieces we could put
them back together again.
If you have a little bit of a
loss it's much more difficult.
So these things are spinning on
the mandrel just short of 200 RPM.
So even a small loss or small
long scratch or crack can lead
to quite a bit of data loss
because it's now every half
second you're seeing a click.
>> Fascinating your
presentation [inaudible].
>> Eric Monroe: Thanks.
>> I was interested in
the long [inaudible].
What are your thoughts
on the [inaudible].
There could be two or three
or perhaps four different
kinds of [inaudible].
I wonder whether there was a
kind of rudimentary [inaudible].
>> Eric Monroe: Okay,
so the question was
in the lab notebooks the
apparent notching of the pages.
They're not notches at all.
Those are little weights that
were used at Rutgers to hold it,
the paper, the pages
flat for imaging.
And so they're not really notches,
not labeling or anything like that.
It was just to hold it flat.
It's the reason why it looked
like he wrote around it is
because they put the
weight so it didn't cover
up anything for us to see.
>> The entry [inaudible] notches
though it looked like birds.
>> Eric Monroe: I think it's felt.
>> Thank you.
>> I just love that we're
all [inaudible] more curious
about the notebooks too.
And I'm wondering if reading those
notebooks has changed the way you
keep your notes?
And the work you've been
doing, do you have good detail?
>> Eric Monroe: I do keep
pretty reasonable with detail.
My handwriting is completely awful.
So mine's all on my or most
of mine's on my computer.
But yeah, that's one of
the things that, you know,
as scientists were taught to do
is lab notebooks are important.
And it turns out that lab
notebooks are really important even
for mundane things that, you
know, you might not think
that someone's going to come looking
at your lab notebook
130 some odd years
after you did the experiment
but it does happen.
>> Fenella France: And basically
we've got a big approach it would be
trying to extract the metadata
from the instruments to sort
of try and make it easier.
Because the last thing you
want to [inaudible] scientist
with doing really cool stuff
like this is make sure you've
written all of it down.
But we all know that we
[inaudible] little things and so
if there's a way to
really capture that.
And it's something that we're
actually working through from some
of the digital perspective to
try and capture [inaudible].
Well if there's no more questions
I want to thank you all for coming.
Thank you to the online [inaudible].
So the talks will be [inaudible]
probably sometime in June.
So watch the online and
watch the space for that.
And we look forward
to seeing you there.
Thank you again to Eric.
>> Eric Monroe: Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.